so i've been so healthy every day i'm
like
taking all my vitamins juicing and
just trying to stay positive well that
combination
has paid off because kelly osborne just
revealed on instagram
that she lost an impressive 85
pounds this is something i've been
working on for a very long time
the reality star who has been very vocal
about her health journey with fans
shared the news after jeannie mai's mom
commented on one of her selfies
saying quote oh my gosh you lost a lot
of
weight kelly responded with that's right
mama mai
i lost 85 pounds since i last saw you
can you believe it you know it's a
commitment kelly's commitment to fitness
has been a journey for the now 35 year
old
in 2011 she opened up to shape magazine
about how growing up in the public eye
and how being bullied because of her
weight
ruined her self-esteem i got sick and
tired of everyone telling me who i was
i wanted to take that pal back and say
you know what this is who i am
now kelly isn't hesitating to show off
how far she's come
she shared a pic of her new size while
shopping on saturday to her insta story
she captioned it quote yes i'm bragging
because i worked hard and it feels good
at the beginning of this year kelly made
it clear that in 2020
she was making herself a priority she
posted this collage to her instagram
captioning it in part quote 2020 is
going to be the year of me
it's time to put myself first and be the
badass
sober woman i was born to be i
am weird and wonderful and
different and content with myself
and that's enough e.t caught up with
kelly in march and she revealed
what she's been doing to stay fit while
in quarantine
seven pounds of quantity wow over what
the last two weeks
wow just from like being healthy juicing
what is it that you're doing
so i wake up and in the morning
and i guess it's what i'm doing is
intermittent fasting if you really think
about it
because i get up i have coffee and then
i juice
until nighttime and then i have like one
meal and then i go to bed
wow so you're juicing all day you don't
have really a breakfast or a
solid like lunch oh my gosh and how do
you feel
i have so much energy it's crazy
i feel like i'm bouncing off the walls
how is it like you get in quarantine and
you're like suddenly like becoming like
fitness guru and
like more energy and happier than you
were before quarantine i don't
know it's the weirdest thing i think
that i just like
as they say went into action rather than
sitting here like in fear